many factors influence the therapeutic
efficacy of a drug including
pharmacokinetics a quantifiable measure
of how the body affects the drug
and pharmacodynamics how the drug
affects the body
pharmacokinetics is a multi-step process
that includes absorption or the movement
of the drug into the bloodstream
distribution or the movement of the drug
through the blood and various tissues of
the body such as brain tissue fat and
muscle
metabolism or the chemical alteration of
the drug by the body
and excretion or the elimination of the
drug by the body
this four-step process is referred to by
the acronym add me
during distribution of certain drugs
proteins present in the bloodstream such
as serum albumin bind the drug and
render it inaccessible to its Target
effective dose concentration is a
measure of Unbound drug present in the
bloodstream
thus pharmacokinetics determines factors
within the body that dictate when and
how much Unbound drug reaches its Target
site after Administration
pharmacodynamics determines how Unbound
drug affects the biochemical and
molecular interactions of its Target
macromolecules
this includes activation or inactivation
of its Target macromolecule
and the specific physiological effects
this produces within the body
the first step leading to this response
is the interaction of the drug with its
Target
the target is either specific such as
particular receptors or enzymes or
non-specific such as neutralizing
stomach acids with antacids
increasing the dosage of most drugs
intensifies the response maximal
efficacy is the largest possible effect
a drug produces
the interaction between pharmacokinetics
and pharmacodynamics governs the
relationship between the dose of the
medication and the desired response
therefore pharmacokinetics and
pharmacodynamics are pivotal in
establishing that therapeutic efficacy
of a drug regimen and producing the
desired effect of a drug
both pharmacokinetics and
pharmacodynamics are affected by
characteristics unique to each patient
such as genetics and physiological
variables such as age